hi guys it's joanna here so you have
been extremely dedicated to your fitness
plan and consuming a well-balanced diet
to achieve your fitness goal but let's
be real it's impossible to stick to a
healthy diet 100 of the time over time
it can be unsustainable and take a
serious toll on you affecting you
emotionally and physically hence it's
okay to let loose once in a while and
enjoy a cheat meal
what are cheat meals it is when you
consciously allow yourself to indulge in
something you would normally stay away
from for almost every meal you should
stick to a well-balanced and nutritious
diet filled with vegetables fruits
protein whole grains and consume the
right amount of calories based on your
needs and goals however it is normal to
crave for the chocolate cookie dough ice
cream cheesecake or other naughty foods
well the good news is having your
favorite naughty food or cheat meal
occasionally can actually help with
weight loss by taking a pre-planned
approach towards eating bad you have the
potential to speed up your weight loss
that's because cheat meals can reset
hormones responsible for metabolism and
insulin regulation replenish glycogen
for increased energy and keep calorie
burning and fat portion mechanisms high
when you know you can be a little looser
with your diet and treat yourself to
those forbidden foods you're more likely
to stay motivated and to stay on track
with your goals so here are seven steps
to eat cheat meals and still lose weight
while i'm not a fan of the word cheat i
think it's perfectly fine to
occasionally indulge just do it smartly
to simply put it if you have just
started a weight loss program or you've
just begun to adopt a healthier
lifestyle then i recommend that you have
a cheat meal only once a week this will
give your mind and body a chance to get
over your withdrawal symptoms of
processed or unhealthy food which you
might have been consuming for many years
having only one cheat meal in a week in
the beginning can also build up focus
and self-control for a long-term success
once you start to embrace your new
fitter and healthier lifestyle and as
you start getting leaner the frequency
of your cheat meals may actually
increase
the lower your body fat levels are the
more your body wants to hang on to the
fat it has
and some of you might hit a weight loss
plateau
now in order to drop the last few pounds
you might actually increase your cheat
meals to twice a week
this will keep your body guessing and
increase your metabolism to continue
burning fat more efficiently
yes even your cheating needs to be
recorded in your food diary this is the
only way you can be certain that you're
not completely ruining your effort for
the entire week remember cheat meals
should not be treated like a buffet it
certainly isn't all you can eat instead
eat between 500 to 1000 calories more
than your usual day although a cheat
meal allows freedom for you to eat what
you would normally avoid you should
still practice self-control and remain
focused on your ultimate fitness goal so
choose one thing you really want whether
it's ice cream or a cake but don't give
yourself excuses to turn that one
indulgence into a whole day or a week of
over indulging
[Music]
many people in the health and fitness
industry actually do not like the word
cheat instead they prefer to look at it
as a reward meal for all the hard work
you have put in i'm sure you might have
noticed when you try to lose weight you
become somewhat of a social outcast you
might not be able to enjoy eating out
with your family and friends as frequent
as you used to so pre-plan your reward
or cheat meal and make it at a time
where it is socially beneficial to you
no matter how we avoid it
bad food always seems to be around when
you're out with your family and friends
so i like to save my cheat meal for the
weekend when i can loosen up and enjoy
my dinner without worrying about having
to say no to every temptation so make it
a time to reward and celebrate your
effort if you associate your treats to
feelings of guilt this can further lead
to loss of control over your meal hence
let it go however if you associate your
treats to celebration you are more
likely to be in control of your eating
habits and know when to stop when you're
satisfied
this leads on to my next step
how many of you have allowed yourself to
indulge in bad food and then feel
extremely guilty afterwards if that
happens on a regular basis it is very
likely that you see food as a threat and
something negative that will sabotage
your fitness goal
just know that no one single food causes
weight gain
weight management is based on your total
calorie intake so if you practice
moderation self-control and seafood as
nourishing both your body and soul
all foods can be part of a healthy
eating plan i believe that in order to
build a positive relationship with food
long term it has to start from within so
change your mindset and food language
instead of saying this food is bad and
high in calories and i feel extremely
guilty eating it
tell yourself
this food has a lot of calories if i
really want it i will enjoy it in
moderation
start changing your mindset and you will
gradually build up a positive
relationship with food which will
contribute to a healthy weight
management long term
the difference between binging and
enjoying a cheat meal is that you know
you're fully in control fully aware and
present with your meal you're able to
eat what you want until you're satisfied
not until you're stuffed
so put effort into your cheat meals when
you indulge serve it on a pretty plate
so that it's appealing to your site
smell your food eat your food slowly by
taking small bites to fully appreciate
the taste and texture don't just gobble
down all your food and avoid eating in
front of any distractions such as the tv
computer or doing any other activity
just by being more aware of what is on
your plate and slowly enjoying it you
will have a much more satisfying and
mindful meal experience without
overeating
a cheat meal should always be within
control so this means learning to give
and take and it's not a license to binge
if you happen to be a dessert lover just
like me
then compromise and go light on your
main course skip the starter drinks and
choose a healthier lower calorie main
course so that you can splurge on
dessert it's all about balance if you
plan ahead and already know what you
want to order prior to visiting a
restaurant then you are more likely to
stick within your portion and enjoy a
satisfying cheat meal
no matter how much we plan and have
strong self-control it is impossible to
be perfect throughout your weight loss
journey sometimes we tend to over
indulge and eat more than what we
intended for our cheat meal or maybe
you're eating more cheat meals than you
planned in a week everyone sleeps up and
that's fine as long as you do not allow
one slip up to turn into a relapse
don't let it be an excuse to get back
into your old eating patterns whenever
you slip up take note learn from it so
that you can anticipate and take control
in the future to sum it up rewarding and
recognizing your effort by enjoying
cheat meals have been proven to increase
motivation and contribute to a higher
success rate in weight loss this is
because cheat meals feed the soul and
feeding the soul keeps your mind and
body at ease so when you're in balance
with yourself you're most likely to stay
focused and achieve your ultimate goal i
hope this video has taught you on how to
be smart with your cheat meals so that
you can maintain a healthy balanced diet
long term if you enjoyed this video then
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to check
out my youtube channel for a lot more
nutritional and fitness tips and also
other workout videos and i will see you
in my next video all the best